[Music]
the daily rising and setting of the
Sun the annual transition between winter
spring summer and
fall the repeated stages of development
of living systems from birth growth
maturity aging and eventual
death much of the world unfolds through
processes like
these that are
[Music]
cyclical so might such rhythmic Cycles
extend beyond those we directly observe
and encounter perhaps being relevant to
the cosmos as a
whole some ancient cultures surely
thought
so Hindu tradition developed a complex
series of time Cycles whose durations
were hundreds of thousands to millions
of years and
Beyond other Traditions by contrast
develop the view that the Universe came
into existence through some kind of
onetime creation event and some also
imagin that it would end through a
one-time
[Music]
Apocalypse in the early years of the
20th century scientists w in with yet
another
perspective that the very concept of a
beginning might only apply to objects in
the universe but not to the universe as
a whole thus suggesting that the
Universe always was and always will be
this in fact was Einstein's view but
only until about 1930 when observations
by Edwin Hubble reveal that the fabric
of space is expanding and so running the
cosmic film back in time
suggesting a singular event from which
everything emerged in a violent swelling
of space the Big
Bang the big bang and its further
refinements has become the dominant
scientific Paradigm for cosmology but in
the 1940s the physicist Richard Tolman
introduced the scientific possibility of
a cyclic Universe imagining that the Big
Bang might be followed by an era of
spatial expansion that would One Day end
end leading to spatial contraction and
the recreation of a dense universe that
then expands a new through another big
bang and the Cycles
repeat further research taking into
account the Relentless rise in entropy
or disorder dictated by the second law
of Thermodynamics reveal that such
Cycles could not have happened
infinitely far into the past the Cycles
themselves must have had a beginning
but an incarnation of a cyclic Universe
has more recently been proposed and its
proponents argue that the Cycles in this
version could have been happening
arbitrarily far back indicating that the
Universe would not have had a
beginning and if their calculations
prove relevant to reality our current
cycle may come to an end sometime in the
far
future
this new perspective on time and
cosmological development offers a
controversial competitor to mainstream
cosmological thinking and if correct
will hearken back to ancient wisdom that
encourages us to reimagine time and
consider a reality not subject to the
usual organization of beginning middle
and
end a reality that in this view May
surprisingly be our
reality good
evening thank
you you know we in science we work often
within Paradigm certain established ways
of thinking about this or that quality
of existence and these paradigms can be
quite useful quite fruitful quite
powerful in guiding our research what we
focus on and the way in which we analyze
and interpret data but every so often we
learn that the Paradigm needs to be
looked at a new sometimes we need to
take a kind of Sledgehammer to the
Paradigm and and break it and start
fresh to free up our thinking and when
it comes to the big questions of
cosmology how did the universe as we
know it come to be we may potentially be
in root to that kind of rethinking at
least According to some of the
scientists that we will have on the
stage here in just a moment because as
we just saw in that piece even Albert
Einstein went through a radical change
in thinking initially anticipating that
on the largest of scales the universe
was fixed Eternal static and
unchanging and then ultimately through
observations that actually comported
well with his own general theory of
relativity Einstein didn't about face
and came to recognize this idea of a
beginning as being relevant to reality
as a whole but just because Einstein
believed it and just because there's
been a great deal of evidence supporting
it it doesn't mean that we don't want to
entertain alternate possibilities that
might fit the data
just as well and indeed that's going to
be the subject that we are going to
explore here this evening with some deep
thinkers who have spent a lot of time
thinking about these issues first up we
have Peter Gallison who is the pelo
University professor of the history of
Science and of physics at Harvard
University he's a leading historian of
science whose research explores the
interaction of experimentation
instrumentation and theory in physics
welcome Peter nice to see you
Brian next we have Anna Yos who is a
senior research scientist at New York
University and a principal investigator
of the Simon initiative new directions
in cosmology and gravitational theory in
her research she studies the origin
structure and evolution of the universe
great to see
[Applause]
you and finally we have Paul steinhardt
who is the Albert Alber Bert Einstein
professor in science and director of the
center for theoretical science at
Princeton University and a prime
architect of our leading cosmological
theories in 2002 his contributions to
science steinhardt was awarded the
prestigious dur
medal good to see
you good to see
you all right let's just maybe begin
with a big sort of overview of the human
urge to understand understand Origins I
mean we see it across cultures there's
almost no culture doesn't come with some
kind of creation myth creation
story where does this urge come from
Peter I think that the attempt to
understand the structure of the universe
as a whole to see the stars and to look
at the Earth the plants the objects the
peoples around us has always seemed to
cultures something that had to be
accounted for and sometimes that's done
with images
sometimes with with stories or accounts
sometimes in books in poems uh but it is
a universal drive to understand why
we're here in the case of of the
scientific tradition that
we're in mesh in right
now the study of the universe as a whole
is a fairly recent Affair and it's
really with Einstein and and one of the
things that's so surprising is that he
finished his general theory of
relativity in 1915 1916 and it was only
a year after that that he began to write
down uh theory of the whole of saying
this this account about gravity and our
experience of it our solar system
perhaps larger structure still was
something that could be thought of as
explaining and accounting for the
universe widely considered not looking
at the little clumps of matter that make
up Earth or Saturn or the Sun but
imagining mass and energy spread out
over the whole and thinking of this as
having a geometry this is really the
birth of of a modern observational
science of cosmology and that's so we're
still in early days we're just over a
hundred years into a history of
cosmology even if the drive to
understand the Universe goes back many
Millennia yeah so so Anna you're in your
scientific career you spent a lot of
time
trying to push the boundaries of our
understanding of cosmological thought
when you think back on the eras that
preceded ours with people like the Matra
and fredman and Einstein we'll perhaps
talk a little bit more about their
contributions do you see yourself
following in their footsteps or do you
see yourself as trying to blaze a
completely new path oh definitely the
first one definitely the first one so
maybe I'll get to that but you know um
and I'm sure that Paul will talk about
it when cosmology really took off um in
the 80s right um then it became your
field it particle physics made it to an
experimental science and I believe you
know a few years ago and we will get
back to that too we might have reached
you know the limit how far we can push
the boundaries of cosmology and our
understanding by just using particle
physics and what I have been doing a few
years ago is actually going back and
seeing maybe we missed something what we
can learn by using general relativity
especially using the mo modern to of
computer computer simulations and maybe
understand more so I definitely see
myself much closer to the matter and
tomman and Einstein then maybe most of
my colleagues who are doing um particle
physics inspired cosmology that was
founded by Paul uh uh are doing so
definitely the first one yeah now that's
an important distinction to make it is
the case now that cosmology is a field
that brings in people from all over but
certainly particle physics gravitational
physics and in the early days it wasn't
so obvious that someone working on the
elementary particles would have
something to say about the largest
structures in the universe so Paul
before we get into sort of the more
modern story of cosmology where you make
a tremendously important Mark can you
just give us a thumbnail sketch going
from Einstein's new view of gravity in
terms of a flexible SpaceTime that can
stretch and swell and so forth the ideas
that then take that picture and turn it
into a cosmological story can you just
give us a feel for how that went sure I
mean it's curious that Einstein had a
theory that space was elastic and could
change with time but came up with a
static model which it was as boring as
possible right so kind of weird
contradiction
and um when a few years later Alexander
fredman showed that the same equations
the same Einstein equations allowed for
the possibility for an expanding
universe or a universe that would expand
for a period and Rec and Rec and
contract and maybe a bouncing universe
that would uh repeat this cyclically
Einstein rejected that he he he he
thought it was well first of all he
thought it was mathematically incorrect
he even wrote a little piece that argued
that it was mathematically wrong and had
to retract it that's right yeah that's
right and obviously it was because it
bothered him philosophically yeah so the
early days of cosmology we also have to
respect the fact that the early days of
cosmology were not well informed by
observations yeah at that time we didn't
even know there were galaxies that was
first around contemporaneous with
fredman and then the idea that there
were Millions no billions of galaxies
out there and they're moving in all
kinds of complicated ways is something
that developed over the course of the
next decade yeah and showed us that the
uh that in fact fredman's idea and
fredman and lra's idea that the Universe
might be expanding was once hot and
dense and has been expanding and cooling
seems to be consistent with the
observations at that time yeah and then
over the course of the century we've
obtained more and more observational
information that reaffirms that part of
the story over and over again yeah and
so so Peter just want to Dr down a
little bit and I don't want to
psychoanalyze Einstein per se but um
here's this radical thinker who gives
this radically new theories Paul was
mentioning where gravity is now who
would have thought gravity is geometry
warps and Curves in SpaceTime it's
flexible and yet when the math suggests
that flexibility applies to the entirety
he recoils now there is some evidence
and I and I wonder if you have a sense
of this that Einstein did not like the
idea a of a dynamic Universe because it
suggested a beginning and a beginning to
him felt too religious too theological
you know I think the idea of a beginning
has been attached to religious accounts
for a long time yeah and in the dispute
for example between those who advocated
for a steady state universe that matter
was popping into existence all the time
versus the idea that there was a big
bang which was only resolved with uh
discoveries in the last decades this
cosmological microwave background that
suffuses the Universe of echo of the Big
Bang um was a big shock and in fact got
theological endorsement the the the big
bang by the pope and more recently Again
by by Fran by Pope Francis that that
somehow the idea of a beginning was
consonant with Biblical Genesis so these
things had a deep root in culture and
philos philosophy I think for Einstein
too Einstein did care about experiment
in observation and the standard view was
the stars are fixed and you know it
wasn't until the work of Edwin Hubble
that you really started to have an idea
that things were expanding so I think
Einstein thought he was saving the
phenomena as they say he he was he was
doing what he had to do to the theory to
make it consonant with what he thought
was standard observation at the time and
certainly was the case when the
observations were overwhelming he didn't
stick to his guns he absolutely turned
around very very quickly on that point
so Anna by you know 1930 there's general
or by 1933 let's say there's General
consensus that the universe is expanding
Einstein's theory in Broad brush Strokes
agrees with this idea and you could even
say predicts it although it wasn't
accepted in that particular particular
temporal order but as people begin to
think more deeply about this idea of a
big bang beginning and everything
swelling from that point cracks begin to
appear or at least issues begin to arise
they often go by the name of say
flatness problem Horizon problem can you
just give it take take one of those and
just give us a sense of what the issue
is so this is tough this is this is we
still haven't through solve this problem
so this is really these are the the
problems at the heart of modern
cosmology uh that you just mentioned and
let's just start with with the big bang
so I don't pick up your your problems
first but let's just start with the big
bang and say why doesn't expanding
Universe imply a big bang as a beginning
yes how do we know that well the answer
is I think we all agree we actually
don't um we are all being thoughted that
if the universe started to expand 13.8
billion years ago then it had to have a
beginning but that's an extreme
extrapolation just because Universe at
some point started to expand it doesn't
imply that it had to have a beginning
because the extrapolation from when the
first element started when the universe
was already cool enough back to
something that we might call the
beginning is actually bigger in
temperature in energy in everything and
we actually don't know the theory that
would describe that phase because that
would require the the marriage of
quantum physics and and and general
relativity and we don't have that theory
so just to quickly jump in just to
clarify I mean the normal the usual
thinking or the usual lore is if the
universe is expanding today you just
kind of wind the cosmic film in Reverse
right and going back it gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and so so it does
suggest that there was some beginning
where everything was small everything is
on top of everything else but I gather
you are suggesting that that's taking
that winding the film backward maybe too
far yeah that's the point because just
because something if you wind back the
film to 13.8 billion years ago it looks
okay but only because we observe it it
could have turn turned out that we shoot
up the satellites look at space because
when we look far enough that means we
look back in time um and we see
something else that's why we are
scientists we assume something but then
we check we check by observation and if
something else comes out then we would
have to conclude we were wrong so we
know that because we check that's what
we know so we know how uh cold and vast
the universe is today uh that has
overall a temperature of 2.7 Kelvin it's
super super cold and then we ex
backwards in time in 13.8 billion years
then we see how hot it was we see the 1
second Mark so 1 second after the
beginning of expansion it was 10 billion
Calin but what you say now is it's
actually worth looking when the next
slide comes by how much further in
energy or in temperature we would have
to ex plate backwards from the first
second Mark to what we call a big bang
well you see it it's a million times a
million times a million times a million
times Calin so it's a huge extrapolation
it's much bigger extrapolation between
whatever the beginning might be and the
first second so if you say oh it is just
a little bit going backwards no that's
just being thought wrong right uh okay
so so you actually it's further from the
first second to whatever it takes plus
we don't have the theory so maybe just
the first thing and now if we get to
your question well actually before I
love the direction you're taking this
can we just follow on that I think I
think it's actually great so you've now
encouraged us to question the intuitive
lore that just because we're expanding
today it had to all come back together
early on so that raises the question of
um there may have been a singular time
for a big bang perhaps there's something
else and you're going to suggest
something else as we go forward not to
uh spoiler alert here but I'd like to
continue on the more traditional
trajectory in order that the new ideas
that you're going to suggest have a
counterpart to bounce off of especially
because Paul you're one of the
architects of the other theory that your
new theory is going to try to undercut
so it's a very you
know interesting situation that we find
ourselves in so when it comes to of of
the Big Bang if there was one certainly
one of the things that we would need to
explain is what drove the outward
expansion and certainly the approach
that you developed inflationary
cosmology at least in principle supplies
an answer to what that outward push
would be so if you're willing to play
along on the old theory that you
developed that you no longer are in
favor of if you could just give us a
sense of what the inflationary Theory
says
um so what was the reasoning behind the
inflationary Theory well the problem
that the big Bank uh presents to us is
that uh as the universe first emerges we
expect there to be large Quantum effects
uh that create wild variations in
SpaceTime itself wild variations in uh
the distribution of energy and
radiation um and and also wild
variations in the Curve of the universe
yeah so if you simply went from that
point forward like the diagram was
suggesting you'd expect by the time you
get to the 1 second Mark you have a
universe that's still very curved with a
very wild distribution of matter and
energy um and remarkably that's not the
case so whereas in general relativity
the least likely thing to have is a
smooth and flat universe it should be
very elastic and wildly varying we
actually need to explain why when we get
to the 1 second Mark some somehow has to
have made it smooth and flat and
observationally we know that at that
Mark and now we can say that we couldn't
say that in the 1980s when inflation was
invented but now we can say in fact
looking at the microwave background we
actually see that large scale
homogeneity compared to the size of the
UN part of the universe that would be
causal contact at that time that could
possibly have we're going to come we're
going to come to the microwave
background and the issue of homogeneity
and the temperatures being uniform on
scales that are hard to explain but can
we first Peter just give us a thumbnail
what is the cosmic micro background
radiation gives me a vital tool in the
conversation so as the universe develops
at a certain point the electrons and the
and the light begin to interact and it
begins to you we can you can see the
Echoes of that radiation uh even today I
mean it's somewhere in the television
channels uh Channel 69 in the usual 1%
of the static or so so when you turn on
your television you're seeing some echo
of that and it can be studied much more
finely first it was discovered in the
60s and then it was with satellites of
increasing accuracy we've been able to
look at finer and finer structures on
this noisy background in the sky and it
amazingly enough enough it looks pretty
much the same in all the different parts
of the sky and at different scales and
if the
universe was developed in isolation from
each other then why should it why should
it have the same structure it's like we
we see this room the temperature is
about the same in different parts we can
explain that because the hot parts and
the cool Parts come to equilibrium but
if they've never been in causal contact
as would seem to be if we run the film
backwards from today then it's a great
mystery how did they get to be so
homogeneous in scale and and space so
that's where perhaps we want to take up
we have a little visual just to
emphasize that particular puzzle if you
imagine looking out from Earth and you
took away all the stars and everything
else that was contributing any other
heat what would be left over is the heat
from The Big Bang that Peter was just
making reference to and the point is the
temperature at widely separated points
in this background radiation is almost
identical to Fantastic accuracy but yet
if you look at a signal that attempts to
establish contact between these widely
separated regions there isn't enough
time for Those Distant regions to have
communicated so how in the world did
they get to the same temperature so as
Anna was describing we have this Theory
from early on expanding Universe it
seems to match the fact that the
galaxies are all moving apart but
there's a real issue that there are
unexplained qualities of the world and
and and and Paul this motivated you
certainly in the
1980s to try to solve that problem right
so the first thing you might try to do
as a theorist is try to keep everything
in place that was there before but add
something that would solve this problem
and that's what inflation uh how
inflation was introduced so something
between the big bang out of which would
come some wild dis you know uh wild
Universe something that would tame it
that would smooth out flatten the
universe well before we reached the
point where the temperature was around
the temperature of the center of the sun
when observations tell us it already was
smooth and flat and the microwave
background reaffirms it so that was that
was that was the idea um it didn't
really explain why the universe started
expand expanding that's not exp in fact
it needs some it's not a complete Theory
inflation itself it needs something
before it that explains how you got to
inflation so the expansion already had
to be happening for some reason um in
order for inflation to have any chance
of Ever Getting start but you did have a
at least in some versions there's a
mechanism by which the expansion is
driven if you have some energy that gets
uniformly distributed through a patch of
space and even in Einstein's basic
general theory of relativity it gives
rise to repulsive gravity something
we've never experience in everyday life
because we only experience clumpy things
like tables and chairs and planets and
stars and so forth but in Einstein's
theory you leverage the fact that it can
have an outward push it could accelerate
the expansion which accelerates the
expans compared to what you would have
gotten straight from the Big Bang and
the concept was that if you can
accelerate this expansion this would
take a very uneven universe and curvy
universe and smooth and straighten it
out that was the concept but before we
go on can we just show a little visual
on that because it's sort of a key idea
so if you imagine just having a shape
that has some curvature to it a simple
shape it looks like a ball but just a
sort of a storybook version of it if we
make this bigger and bigger through
rapid expansion it looks flatter and
flatter and so even something that have
some curvature you it's why we think
that the Earth was flat you know you
know 10,000 years ago right because it
does look flat locally so if you can
have this accelerate expansion your
theory together with Alan Guth and Andre
Lind and your student I guess Andreas
albre as well you had this proposal for
how you get rid of the wild undulations
get rid of the curvature as well as find
that these distant locations would be
able to be in causal contact early on
before they got rapidly separated so it
starts out really small and in
equilibrium expands faster than it would
have under the big bang and then it
begins its more stately March through
time right so it's some it'll be
important for our later discussion that
embedded in our minds was the idea that
the only way to smooth the universe yeah
was to make sure that distant regions
were at causal contact much closer
together in the past than the Big Bang
model so you got them really close
together in the past in in the
inflationary Theory and then inflation
sort of lets them catch up to where they
otherwise would have been so they can
start closer together so Anna you must
have learned about the inflationary
Theory as a as a student I mean how was
it presented to you as as you know the
theory it was the way of thinking about
how the universe evolved from the
earliest fraction of a second yeah you
ask actually at the right time because
so so I am younger than
inflation so I didn't have a chance to
contribute to it and I'm younger than it
uh and so when I came to it first time
it was over 10 years ago I was a student
um and it was textbook material so I was
fairly young and um everything what was
just said now was presented in class and
not as
possibility but as something that's been
established and what just por I
explained is something that I remember
it I when I first heard about first
heard about the theory I just thought
this is nuts because it's really nuts
because these guys tell me that they
explain the
smoothness by assuming it and that
somehow sounds good because if if you
remember what Paul said well we just
wanted to put things into causal contact
and how inflation operates is and it is
pretty clear how it's being taught is
that you take things out of causal
contact very rapidly and then when
inflation stops and the expansion starts
a slow expansion and these things come
back again into causal contact and it
looks like that everything uh um is the
same and the reason would be because it
was the same but you correct me the idea
was though and that's why we started
with the big bang that we have to
explain this smoothness
um this
uniformity uh starting from arbitrary
conditions starting from conditions that
quantum gravity would give us and that's
not smooth that's that's it just it just
seemed to me like these guys actually
assumed what they want to explain and
they just made a little trick by saying
okay we assume that some part of space
looked already right and we try to blow
that up over many many many parts of
space and then we somehow have the right
answer but and this is actually what I
came back to then later 10 years later
to work on it really doesn't work so it
really what and and we will get back to
that later it really was the you know my
impression as a student I don't want to
work on this I don't want to stay away
from this because somehow people came to
believe that if they start from the
right condition then they can explain
the same conditions on larger scales but
at the same time they also believe that
somehow generic that somehow comes out
of the big bang and for me this
connection this long connection what's
up there was always missing so I decided
I will not work on this I will just do
something completely different I don't
want to have anything to do with
cosmology and I actually really started
to work like that until I met Paul uh
three years later in Harvard so we'll
pick up your story of where you
ultimately did come back to cosmology in
just a moment but but
Peter can you Channel if you would just
to give us an accurate snapshot of where
people's minds are in cosmology you
today how is the inflationary Theory
again you know developed by Alan Guth
Andre Lind Paul and so forth how is that
viewed in the community right
now I'd say the ma the majority view is
that some version of it is right
although we may not have the right model
there may be things that have to be
adjusted or changed but that basically
something like that so the general
Paradigm that there was a early period
of Rapid expansion that can do these
tricks of bringing things into calls of
contact and pushing them apart that
that's the basic yeah I what honest said
it it pushes it it pushes the problem
back towards the Big Bang Yeah and
allows us to have an account for things
like the causal connection that
otherwise seems impossible to explain
but um it comes at a cost and we'll be
talking about that cost momentarily and
so I'd like to give you guys the floor
in just a moment to go in a in a
direction that you think may be more
fruitful to filling in that part of our
past but again from a more sociological
standpoint I mean just thinking
historically is it common that there are
periods of time where everybody thinks X
but it's really y I mean is that a
rarity you know and and how would we fit
into that historical
Rhythm so I mean certainly have been
periods where the consensus was against
special relativity against general
relativity against it because it seemed
philosophically impossible or it had too
much mathematics this what to the
physicists was unimaginably difficult
differential geometry uh uh which is now
taught as part of mechanics and the
ordinary course of things but at the
time was shocking the development of
quantum mechanics upset people hugely
including uh are Einstein uh there have
been times when major so there certainly
have been times when majority views have
been disrupted by alternative views once
a view is established though it's hard
to get rid of it without an alternative
and I think one thing that I mean just
to anticipate a little bit is I think
having an alternative is always helpful
to the articulation of where we are in
science so Einstein's theory for a long
time didn't really have any alternative
Brans and dicki came up with this
alternative Theory I'd say it's a
minority quite significant minority of
physicists who today think that's the
way to go yeah but the very fact that
there was an alternative pushed people
to think about testing to look at what
is the what are the fragile parts of
Einstein's theory and where where can we
push it with observation and and and
inquiry in in different forms so I as I
say to to anticipate a little bit I
think there's a
an absolute good in having an Al
alternatives to a dominant Theory
whether it's general relativity or
inflation or the Big Bang uh because it
it forces us to articulate where we are
yeah and what the different aspects of
the theory really ought to be so so Paul
Anna mentioned and showed that in that
nice graphic of just how significant an
extrapolation it is to go from things
that we know to things that we want to
understand but don't have direct
observational evidence for and so on so
if you're going to imagine something
other than a
bang what is the next option that comes
to mind than that you've been developing
well an alternative that people even
thought back thought about back in the
1920s is a bounce that the Universe
going backwards in time would be
contracting okay and at some some point
would at some stage would reverse to
expansion yeah in fact I guess Richard
Tolman I guess is among the more
well-known of people there may have been
others who were thinking about like
fredman as well but um so tomman my
understanding is he tried to make that
idea work this notion of a of a bounce
work it was it was freedman's idea and
he was trying to um explore Freeman's
idea and whether it could be consistent
with the laws of thermodynamics the
second law of Thermodynamics and how was
that received back then when it was
initially introduced it was a big blow
to the idea of a cyclic universe so the
so the so the idea of a cyclic Universe
had been around since fredman uh and
when we discovered that the universe is
expanding that was on the list of
possibilities that that the Universe
could then begin Contracting and and and
bounce um and that this would get rid of
the problem of having a beginning of
time time if it were cyclical forever in
the forever into the past uh and that
intrigued people but Tolman pointed out
because you wouldn't have to explain why
there's a universe at all you just say
there always was a universe it's just
been expanding Contracting forever it's
another logical possibility yeah maybe
we're spending a lot of time trying to
explain something the Big Bang which
never happened so maybe there's another
logical possibility to be explored and
ultimately you want to turn that into a
theory that has testable consequences so
tomman was exploring exploring that idea
I should I should emphasize that the
idea of bouncing in those days was that
you would bounce until all of SpaceTime
disappeared and then reappeared and and
then uh expanded and contracted and
disappeared again so it was this kind of
bouncing universe and it led to this
kind of problem that Tolman pointed out
that uh if you think about the disorder
in the
universe the entropy or disorder in the
universe whatever disorder you had in
one cycle would be Rec contracted or
reconcentrated as the universe
approached the bounce came to zero size
and would be there when the universe
began the next bounce but it would
influence through its gravity
gravitational effect that next bounce so
instead of that next bounce being
identical to the one before it now has
whatever disorder it's going to produce
plus the sum of all the disorders of all
earlier cycles and then he showed that
that meant that the Cycles couldn't be
identical obviously there's something
you can measure about the universe that
would the amount of disorder that would
distinguish one cycle to the other and
the Cycles in fact must be growing in
time going a growing in duration going
forward in time which means if you go
back backwards in time they were
Contracting rapidly to zero so you
didn't get rid of the beginning issue
you got back to the beginning uh and so
that um discouraged that and other other
historical facts discouraged people from
thinking about cyclic models for a
number of decades yeah basically nobody
really took the idea seriously until the
work that you have recently pioneered
right there hasn't been much in cylic
cosmology since tomman right uh well in
bouncing cosmology there was a movement
in the 50s and 60s where people began to
think about the idea that the Universe
could have undergone a per period of
contraction into a bounce and then
expansion um it ran into yet other
problems whenever you concentrated the
universe to a point uh that meant all
the matter and radiation that existed in
the before the bounds was being
scrunched together and when you scrunch
that much energy together uh you can't
really predict what's going to happen
next there's no particular reason why
you it would bounce when you because of
its gravity strong gravity holding it
together yeah so that that was a concern
and then another concern was as the
universe contracted in those models um
there was a instability in which you
would begin to um change shape in wild
ways depending upon which point in space
you were observing from uh and that
essentially it was DEH homogenizing the
universe it was messing it up as much as
you could possibly imagine so you had
three problems with cyclic models
tolman's entropy problem what do you do
about crunching all this stuff together
how do you survive that and ever have a
bounce and what do you do about the
inhomogenity you would naturally create
during the kind of
contraction uh kind of contractions that
people were thinking about in the 50s
and 60s right so I think that's a a good
motivation to uh think now more fully
about the work that you and Anna and
other collaborators have been working on
because I gather you claim that in your
version of this cyclic cosmology you
have resolved the majority if not all of
the problems that beset it early on so
however best to explain it Anna Paul
just give us uh a sketch and then I
think you have some nice simulations
that will both argue for your approach
and also against the inflationary
approach trying to bolster the case for
this reimagining of
cosmology sure I can start yeah go ahead
okay so so I think you know the three
problems that Paul mentioned they really
affect two phases actually three because
so one point we call it cyclic cosmology
but one point that we often tend to
forget is and that was what Paul was
talking about in the 50s and 60s there
really are two different scenarios we
could imagine a universe that started to
contract bounced and now expands forever
maybe that will be I think we have to
fix first that scenario is that possible
if that's not possible you will not get
a cyclic cosmology and it's easier to
fix in a certain sense because then
because that doesn't suffer from all of
let's say the torment problems what
happens if the expansion stops and goes
over to contraction can can you do that
just get one cycle to work get go get
one cycle done and this this is really
where we started and again even the
cycle the only thing what we know how to
describe today is the expanding part we
know that nobody debates about it that's
what we call the consensus mod or Lambda
CDM so what we have to fix is can we
describe this Contracting phase that in
particular that it approaches the bounce
without this crazy chaotic Behavior
because if and and at the same time
Smooths the universe so that once we
bounce we see exactly the universe as we
observe it in the microwave background
so that's the one question is there a
good theoretical model for the
Contracting phase yeah and we will start
with that and then the second part is
and I imagine Paul we tell more about it
it's a different story can we really
let's say the Contracting phase works
and we will see that does that's easy we
don't have to bring in new physics we
don't have to do anything about quantum
gravity we just we just really use
general relativity and some new
computational tools but then the second
question is once everything is fine can
we balce that will be much harder so
that's the second part and the third
part is if we can contract pounds expand
can we start again to repeat over and
over without suffering from the entropy
problem so I think these are the three
points we should go through um all right
so can you get the Contracting phase to
work yeah so one thing that we um that I
think that we should um talk about is
that there's um not just a single kind
of contraction and not just a single
kind of Bounce so up until our work when
people were thinking about bouncing
universes they were thinking something
that would be analogous to a balloon
that was collapsing to zero and
expanding and collapsing to zero and
expanding so the thing that was cycling
was what we call this amount of
stretching or the scale factor yes that
was the important cycl cycling uh Factor
but there's another thing in general
relativity you have to keep track of in
cosmology which is what we call the
horizon or the h volume how much is in
causal contact those things that can
actually send signals to each other and
perhaps get to the same temperat like
what you were drawing in in the figure
before and it the the the Hubble Horizon
is how far you can see so an observer in
the universe like us can only see as far
as their Horizon they can't see the
entire space so think about a little
circle on our on our uh balloon which
would represent if you were standing in
the middle of it the Horizon how far you
could see yeah well the thing is the how
much how fast the universe expands or
stretches is different from how much the
Hubble Horizon stretches so whereas
before we were thinking about a universe
in which uh the entire balloon was
shrinking and expanding let's imagine
instead just the observable universe
were shrinking expanding in a cyclical
way yeah space would always exist in
fact space could be continually
expanding but the amount you could see
if you're an observer in the Universe
since you can only see a limited region
of the universe would look the same from
cycle to cycle if you looked in your
environment same as if you were on if
you imagine that on a planet that was
expanding or Contracting but you had a
limited Horizon so that means you don't
have to have space shrink to zero to
have a cyclic Universe it's really a
fundamental different kind of cyclic
universe that means space is ordinary
during the bounce uh it also means
anything that was in your horizon before
the contraction began like the amount of
disorder in entropy has been stretching
out while the Horizon is contracted so
yes there's lots of disorder out there
but it's been spread out uh to parts of
space that you cannot observe so this is
really a fundamental different kind of
cyclic universe that evades the disorder
problem okay it also happens to be that
this condition also prevents the kind of
chaotic effects we're talking about uh
that that were discussed in the 50s and
60s and you never have crunching because
you know on average space is always
expanding I see so if you're focusing
your attention on the part of space that
we observe we don't have to use the
language that perhaps you would have
invoked in an ordinary cyclic Theory
everything is crushed together and then
re-expands and in that way you're
avoiding the more thorny parts of how a
bouncing cosmology would need to to be
developed yeah you're getting rid of the
crunch what we sometimes call Crunch
it's a crunchless bouncing you still
need to ensure that during that phase of
contraction you're setting us up for
Success yes after that phase concludes
and we go into the more ordinary
expanding phase so are you I mean is it
the case that you can set up the model
in such a way that the conditions at the
end of this contraction phase will yield
a universe like the one that we see
on I can I can jump in because because I
I think it's it's it's actually worth
rephrasing just once more in the
language that we used earlier what Paul
said because it's really a fundamental
feature of Relativity that inflation Ed
that we used to explain themas the the
consensus model also contraction that
given what fills the universe the rate
at which your caal connectedness the
radius of coal connectedness evolves can
be very different from the rate at which
space expand BS or contracts so it's all
the same trick so what we see um um
let's say the the slowly expanding
Universe we know that space expands
slower than the region of coal
connectedness so stuff comes into us
that's that's that's the consensus model
that's why we needed inflation now it's
very natural to say well can we uh find
a model can we find some stuff energy
density that during a Contracting phase
we make the the region the space
contract much slower than the region of
coal connectedness because what happens
is you sh a huge amount of space and
instead of doing much to space so let's
say if you start with a w space a
universe like today full of black holes
and you ask um what kind of contraction
do we need then we would need a type of
contraction in which black holes stay
approximately at the same distance they
come a little bit closer but not much at
the same time though the radius of coal
connectedness sh drinks very rapidly and
that's what you need and the nice thing
is that we can do that in relativity so
what this model needed to be fixed is uh
is something that people in the 20s 30s
50s 60s 70s would never have thought
about we as a matter of fact inflation
and all the ingredients that that people
in the 80s invented um something what we
know from the hixus scaler field from
particle physics that can actually uh
Trigger or excert this behavior that
space tracks very slowly but the causal
Horizon shrinks very rapidly and this is
exactly what can be done so that solves
the problem of no chaos and everything
is smooth and uniform as space contracts
and goes to the uh goes towards the
bounds moreover it's really important to
note we don't need new physics so it's
all general relativity uh quantum
physics only enters on small scales and
no quantum gravity is required and all
ingredient what's require bi is that we
are very familiar with in physics it's a
scalar field that dominates this energy
density and is this a a simulation that
can give us some numerical evidence for
what it is that you were referring to do
you want yeah so so let's go back let's
not start the simulation so I think we
should pan back a little bit and just
talk about the role simulations plays
yeah so cosmology started first as
pencil and paper yeah then we went to
particle physics observations and then
then what came up really the last 20 to
30 years is we actually can rerun the
universe without putting up satellites
to look at our current universe but we
can simulate the universe and I think
before we you know describe maybe the
features maybe Peter want to comment
yeah I mean how have we gotten to a
place where there's you know a third way
I mean there's Theory there's
observation experiment simulation I mean
what role is simulation playing in these
Cutting Edge ideas well I I think that
starting in the period at the end of and
just after World War II you had
physicists thinking about the hydrogen
bombs this is what Oppenheimer much on
everyone's Minds these days uh was
concerned about he objected to its
building teller wanted to build it Stan
ulam a mathematician began to think
about a way of doing it but the hydrogen
bomb unlike the atomic bomb used
basically all of our physics how
radiation is transported hydrodynamics
nuclear physics the whole works and you
couldn't do it with pencil and paper or
even with the sort of old adding
machines that were available at Los
Alamos and so ulam and Von noyon began
to think well maybe there's a kind of
game you could play where you know if
you wanted to simulate the diffusion of
a red dye in a thin tube of water you
sort of could flip a coin and go to the
right if it was heads and left if it was
tails and do this over and over over
again and you could model how the
diffusion worked and that's a red
molecule that's going right or left
exactly and you could see how they
accumulated and what the distribution
was and suddenly people began to think
well maybe we could use this to simulate
these very complicated processes where
radiation is coming in and and we use it
more and more it's been a big slow
process over the 50s and 60s and 70s I
remember times when you see an
astronomer would say well you made a
simulation that showed that such and
such an effect works but what's the real
equations that tell us this but at a
certain point people stopped asking that
question the simulations were what you
needed to understand Galaxy formation
and neutron stars these very complicated
objects that are like the nucleus of an
atom but much bigger and you have
thermonuclear explosions going on in the
surface and new forms of matter at the
inside and there's so many things in
astrophysics that require this but not
just astrophysics particle physics what
goes on at CERN or firy laab or or or or
any of the other accelerator
Laboratories what goes on in the plasma
physics lab these experiments to do
nuclear fusion all of this requires
simulations so when it came time to look
at colliding black holes you needed
these numerical methods that could take
you from Pure description of independent
black holes to this merging process and
those numerical techniques um have then
been adapted by Anna to to to to look at
the early universe and those techniques
were vital to the success of Lio right
vital you like I mean Lio was like
jumping out of a window from a high
building hoping you could invent just
Lio is the gravitational wave detector I
think most people are familiar finding
the first ripples in the fabric of space
but when the signal goes by you don't
know what it means if you don't have
some library of simulations that you can
compare the signal to so without those
Sim ulations it would have been lost on
us that the signal absolutely crucial
and in so many areas of Science and in
ligo you need these numerical
simulations so there is a kind of
there's experiment or observation
there's Theory and there's this terium
quid this third thing which is
simulations and that's the world of
science that we live in now in more and
more areas so I think that's a kind of
background to the important work that
Anna's been doing uh to try to give us a
picture of this very this this this
these gravitational uh intense moments
in the early universe and how it works
so this this quick little simulation
that I think we we already saw we can
run it again tell us what it's meant to
show us so um just just one you know two
sentences maybe because we swallow it so
often so we should appreciate that we
have relativity for over 100 years yeah
but it took almost 80 years since we had
relativity to put the equations on the
computer so this is really difficult
it's it's not because that's one thing
that we didn't immediately have the
computers but it required a lot of math
and a lot of computational skills so
it's amazing that we have it yeah and
then we first did it for black HSE and
then what we also figured and this
really actually relates back to where I
was stuck as a student with inflation
and there simulations are crucial so can
we really check that the theory starting
from arbitrary condition arbitrary arit
conditions arbitrary distribution of
energy arbitrary initial geometry so we
can test what would be after the bang
and we could test how what kind of
condition a Contracting Universe could
start from and this is exactly what we
can do so that's one example of this
simulation of this this is what we see
there we can see it repeatedly but I
briefly describe what happened so we
take the Einstein equations yeah and put
them on the computer and the feature of
the Einstein equations is that you can
give them some initial distribution of
matter and initial distribution of
geometry so it can be and that's what we
see there so we see that these omegas
they just represent distribution of
curvature we talked about curvature that
would be if it's flat then it's good if
there is no curvature then it should be
at zero so there and there that should
be a sheet and the same same is uh uh
true for this uh Omega s which is an
isotropy so curvature would tell you
gradients how directed uh the the the
geometry is how much uh uh directedness
how much it matters uh which direction
you look and U an isotropy would tell
you how much sheer there is in in the
universe so we know that there are
almost infinitely many so geometries
possible at the beginning of the
Contracting phase and it's a good theory
if whatever we give to the universe lots
of sheer lots of curvature it all goes
away right it should go away and we only
can do this only can test all these
universes by simulations so we cannot
rerun our universe and that's what it
shows so if you it's it's very quick so
it's it it is and this is amazing
because that's one of the thing is so
this is a representative example of a
very curved and uh a universe which is
full of sheer so we thought people
thought in the 50s 60s that will
definitely lead to this chaos but now we
put in this third ingredient that we
talked about the scalar field yeah that
should do this magic that while space
hardly contracts the caal connect region
of causal connectedness just shrinks
down and if that's true then what one
would see is one sheet up there which is
blue completely uniform and the sheet of
curvature and an isot Shear just
vanishes at zero no contribution to the
energy density so this boring outcome of
the simulation is actually our universe
so we do a lot of work to see something
boring at the end I always so the fact
that it's nice and flat at the end tells
you that regardless of what chaos you
had before it got to the end of the
contraction phase it gets resolved wiped
out and you've got a nice
Placid starting point for the expanding
phase now it also shows it's really fast
it does go a little bit fast so on the
one hand it's disappointing you'd like
to see a simulation which has a lot of
action yeah but there's actually a
really important message there that this
slow contraction compared to inflation
is much you know is very fast in
smoothing the universe so it's very
effective at doing what inflation itself
is claiming contract so the universe
only has to contract by a factor of two
to produce enough smoothing and
flattening to take us from a wildly
inhomogeneous Universe to a universe as
smooth as what we see in the microwave
so you view this as a strong piece of of
simulated theoretical evidence that a
period of slow contraction does the work
necessary to set us up for an eventual
Evolution that yields a universe like
the one we're familiar with you have
some simulations that I gather also take
a look at the inflationary model to see
whether it does the work that it was
claimed to have done so I think we have
that on hand before we do that I want to
make one other point uh because we
discovered something with these
simulations that we didn't anticipate
okay so when you saw that originally
curvy Treet that's that's spanning
directions uh regions of space which are
not in causal contact and because the
contraction is so little in fact they
never become in causal contact yet
somehow magically we ended up with the
smooth
Universe this changes our assum this
goes back to our assumption that we
thought we needed to put things in
causal contact in order to smooth them
out that's true in an expanding universe
that's your only hope in an expanding
universe but in a Contracting Universe
what happens is that different regions
of space will independently smooth
of each other even though they're out of
causal contact in fact what happens is
because the Horizon shrinks so little
very quickly All Points become
disconnected from one another which
means that the equations that they
follow now don't depend on their
neighbors they only depend upon what's
left after you ignore your neighbors
that's the same for every point and
that's why they converge so rapidly to
the same final thing this is a new
phenomenon we call it ultral locality
the context in this context so they're
all dynamically going to the same state
as opposed to interacting in order to
negotiate coming to the same they don't
have to negotiate and it's really
important one point because you know we
tend to always think Newtonian but you
would think if something contracts it
collapses so it's the opposite of what's
happening so it becomes more messy not
local but what we discovered is that's
really Newtonian and now you see when
you simulate relativity how different
the universe that's govern where gravity
is governed by relativity and not
neonian physics is because contraction
doesn't have to be collapsed it's
actually you know the gradi the the
directionality this mess vanish it C all
curvature immediately goes down so that
also represents that you know our
picture of of gravity really has to be
radically revised whenever we we
whenever relativity is important so
contraction is not collaps and that's
why the previous simulation show and
that that's the reason why uh um
everything gets smooth because you know
you just the Contracting phase is
exactly the opposite as you would expect
it doesn't mess things up but smooth
things and and you cannot help it no
matter where you are in every
little uh causally connected space will
look the same because it cannot do it
otherwise and it's it's done to
relativity and that's very different as
Paul will I think explain an inflation
and it and and part of one of the things
that happens there I said is that
neighbors become unaware of one another
so in terms of general relativity that
means that what we call gradients the
variation from point to point those
become irrelevant every point is
operating independently right it's a
feature that's specifically for
contraction so now we can turn well what
about expansion yeah what happens there
well our intuition had about inflation
had been if we began with some very
inhomogeneous Universe okay then
essentially what in inflation does is
stretch it yeah and as it stretches and
if you think about a curvy rubber sheet
it's and winkly rubber sheet you think
it's going to smooth it out but that's a
very bad metaphor for general relativity
because in a rubber sheet those wrinkles
don't resist the expansion but in
general relativity A Wrinkle In
SpaceTime has stress energy that
gravitates itself and wants to fold it
out itself up more so what you really
have is a competition between whatever
wild initial conditions you have that
want to fold themselves up versus
whatever is trying to inflate and the
question is which one wins okay so now
we've taken the same techniques that
Anna developed for contraction and then
she repeated it for expansion again
we're beginning with a universe like
before with the green represents how
much sheer there is in the universe so
it's almost all sheer in the universe
the red represents how much matter and
the blue represents how much curvature
you have and so if you go back to the
beginning go back to the the beginning
again now you begin with a different
vantage point because in this case the
opposite happens than what we saw in the
contraction case where everything
smoothed right now what happens is
things get Wilder and Wilder and Wilder
and that's because you're it's just with
the effect I talked about if your
fluctuate if your initial variations are
wild enough they actually resist the
expansion prevent inflation from taking
hold in fact they grow in intensity
becoming more and more resistant to the
expansion again that's only possible to
learn when we have simulations we could
not have gotten that out of solving with
p pencil and paper equ and so the
proponents of
inflation uh what what is their reaction
to these simulations they're overcome
they're overcome by the variations in
shear and and curvature they can they
can never take hold relative to them
because what you you see when the uh
when you see the curvature going yes you
know but I think you're answering what
happens to the uh structure of SpaceTime
I was actually talking about the people
who
um who who are in the inflationary
mindset when when when you've presented
like these simulations what's the what's
the
response um I think it's a little early
to say because what I've shown you here
is only a few months old so the word
hasn't really gotten out to see see uh
to see every all the all the work that
we've done on the inflationary case and
to contrast the two so I think this is
something which I hope will be one of
the things that contributes to people
opening up their minds to the idea that
slow contraction really is a powerful
smoother for this subtle reason that I
call Ultra locality this subtle feature
of general relativity and the converse
of that is that it's a challenge or
problem for inflation that inflation
unless you begin very close to smooth to
begin with
can never take hold and um in any theory
of course you're making a variety of
assumptions and we're not looking under
the hood right now can you give us a
feel for what kind of assumptions go
into this are are are you making a
variety of choices of uh the behavior of
these fields that are driving part of
the Dynamics here how how generic would
you say that these results are yeah the
the the basic thing you that the basic
uh quantity that you're uh besides the
shear and curvature which are already
part of general relativity the the
component and just give people a sense
of sheer it's the way in which space is
in some sense pulling on itself
stretching this way while pulling this
or something like that the same effect
the gravitational waves produce when
they pass through a detector they
stretch it in some directions and
contract other directions and so that's
a kind of you know uh unevenness yes to
SpaceTime and would make an unevenness
in uh Cur uh in um the distribution of
matter and energy and how everything
behaves so the the thing the component
that you're adding for inflation was a
scaler field which had a property that
it induced accelerated expansion yeah
and here you're doing something
analogous you're producing introducing a
scalar field its details are different
but it has the property that it causes
this slow
contraction um and in terms of uh the
ingredient it's it's very similar it's a
scale it's some field um it's just the
details of how its energy depends on its
strength field strength that what I was
sort of driving at do you have to
fine-tune that in any way I mean
certainly you have to fine-tune it
inflation to make sure that this
ingredient gives rise to that energy we
were talking about that can give the
repulsive push that drives inflation how
much tuning do you have to do within the
theory to make this behave as we've just
seen um I mean we have we have studied
that you can run the simulations with
varying also the ingredients so we call
that the potential energy of the
ingredient and what's interesting it's
actually relatively insensitive but I
should say that in inflation it's Al so
the two pictures that we saw they are
fairly generic for both scenario so we
did just on the scale of hundreds and
thousands so it's very Qui quick to do
very quick to run the simulations you
know what you saw it's maybe 30 minutes
uh for contraction so we could run
during the last few years hundreds of
simulations so this is very generic um
you don't really I I don't think that
this at this level it involves the type
of tuning that you might need to fit the
little Wiggles in the microwave
background and then in inflation what
happens is because it's so complicated
it actually takes much longer to run the
simulation sometimes the same simulation
the same initial conditions takes a week
or more just just for for comparing
until it runs and but I would say that
that's also fairly generic so we have
Nan also there hundreds of simulations
with different types of potentials and
the outcome what you see this contrast
that the one Smooths and the other one
not that's not tuned in either case and
where tuning comes in I think is and
maybe they'll get back to this what the
quantum effects how we moderate the
quantum effects in both theories now now
we called this session reimagining Time
Peter because part of the idea is if a
bounce can happen and I'll turn to you
guys in a moment maybe many bounces can
happen if many bounces happen maybe time
doesn't start maybe time doesn't have a
beginning how how do you if that's where
this goes how do you think that begins
to realign people's thinking on on how
we fit into some grander Cosmic order
you know I think in the largest
frame we're caught in science with an
implicit conflict of philosophy on the
one side we don't want to be special
we'd like to have a machine that
predicts a theoretical machine that
predicts the universe without having to
tune many different knobs exactly right
uh and have everything fall apart in its
predictive power if they weren't tuned
just right it would all fall AP we we
don't want a machine that requires such
exact tuning and by machine I mean the
theoretical apparatus yeah um we you
know even from the time of cernus
uh I mean cernus said we're we're not
special we're not at the center of the
universe and this was you know then oand
wrote this preface saying he's just
kidding
basically read it it's really great
mathematics it's great for predicting
where the planets will appear to be but
he doesn't really mean we're not at the
center of the universe because this was
a fundamental
anxiety that's a kind of spatial
specialness and then there's the
temporal specialness we you know we have
this long tradition in in uh
judeo-christian thought and in others
that there's a moment of creation yeah
and that's
been objected to by scientists at
different phases who didn't want there
to be a special uh time of the beginning
and that maybe the universe was popping
into existence all the time and just
expanding as I mentioned before that got
defeated by the early measurement of the
cosmic microwave background but these
two conflicting desires to to to have to
to have a point of origin uh in space
and in time a specialness Freud once
said there were three great blows to our
Collective understanding that cernus
took us out of the center of the
universe Darwin took us out of the
center of species and psycho took us out
or that the ego is no longer master of
its own house as he once said and I I
think that those blows to specialness
looking for something that's constant is
a is a theme that comes up in cosmology
often and I think you know there is a
sense of you know that I think lies
behind the thinking about the cyclic
Universe of saying we don't want to have
a one special moment we want to be a
process that exists over time so I think
these these these con these conflicting
desires I mean there's a philosophy that
people can make and say oh let's make
special philosophical inquiries about
things and then there's a philosophy
that's embedded in the practice of
science itself yeah and you know we are
driven towards these questions is there
an absolute time is there an absolute
space is there a beginning is I mean is
our galaxy special uh all of these
questions keep coming back and usefully
so they Propel us to think imag atively
and to think otherwise to think
alternatively to say maybe not the big
bang maybe something cyclic so I think
these questions really are they run deep
and long in the history of science yeah
so given that as sort of the
philosophical backdrop you've argued so
far that there is this framework in
which if the universe contracts and then
expands it can very easily according to
your simulations give rise to a universe
that we're familiar with you've also
argued that the previous theories have a
hard time doing it now can you repeat
this trick and have that expanding phase
go into a Contracting phase and thereby
perhaps not have a beginning to time if
these Cycles were to continue eternally
sure um yes it all depends on the shape
of this potential curve for this scaler
field and the potential curve again is
just how much energy this field has when
it has a particular Val in space so it's
kind of changing its value and then that
changes its potential energy and how
that rate of change change how that
changes with time
determines uh rates of expansion or
contraction how the Hubble volume or how
the causal volume changes relative to
the expansion rate so in the moment
we're in an interesting situation in the
universe where the expansion rate is
accelerating we discovered that back in
the in the in 1998 yeah the expansion of
the universe is speeding up up at
present now you might wonder then how do
we ever return to a universe that is
Contracting uh if you're trying to make
a bounce in the future the answer is you
can imagine that what's happening at the
moment is that this potential energy
curve is right now it has a positive
value but it's decreasing in strength
it's decreasing as the field evolves and
if it decreases to the point that it
goes below zero becomes negative this is
exactly the condition you need to get
the slow contraction condition so it
actually is not hard as you might think
at first to go from today's accelerated
expansion to the end of acceleration as
we hit the zero potential to slow
contraction it's like rolling off a log
in a sense you actually have no choice
in such a scenario as to what happens to
the universe it will definitely enter a
period of of contraction uh and then you
could ask a the question well how far in
the future might that be I was actually
going to ask that question yes let's see
what time is it I
know well the answer could it depends on
how steep you would make this curve um
and you might think that well maybe it
takes billions of years before this
might happen but it could be
surprisingly shorter than that it could
be as short as a 100 million years and
maybe even shorter and the reason why it
can be as soon as that which I call it
soon well compared to the age of the
dinosaurs I picked that number
intentionally that's roughly the time
since the dinosaurs to the present could
be how far to the Future So cosmically
speaking that's actually a very short
period of time yeah know it's a blink of
an eye cosmically speaking so so so one
of the things we have to appreciate when
we say the universe is accelerating what
information are we using to get to get
that conclusion we're measuring the
expansion rate at Early times when
Supernova certain Supernova at very
large distances were exploding and we're
using those Supernova at Great distances
which emitted their light long ago to
infer that we've gone through some
acceleration but if you ask what's
happening now we have no information
that tell telling us exactly what's
happening now and that's why it could be
that we're already well on the road to
end of acceleration and contraction and
we wouldn't know it
we very we wouldn't know it so there
could be a cult forming
soon the end of times are near the end
of our cycle is near well for us that
would be the end of of of times can't
have
everything and a and so is this a point
of view that you view sort of abstractly
I mean this is a radically different
future in the conventional story of the
our future right you know we love to
extrapolate in science and we talk about
you know what happens in you know 10 to
the 20 years from now maybe the Earth
will spiral into the sun because it lost
energy through gravitational radiation
10 to the 30 years we imagine Stars
cycling into the black holes in the
center of their galaxies 10 to the 38
years we imagine protons disintegrating
all matter falling apart 10 to the 50
years the end of thought the universe
can't absorb the from the process of
thinking itself 10 to the 68 years we
talk about solar mass black holes
evaporating 10 to the hundred years we
think about enormous Galactic scale
black holes evaporating you're telling
us that those are ridiculous time scales
potentially to even be thinking about
yeah it could be it could exactly
there's another there's another possible
story and we'd have no way of refuting
it given what we what we know at present
wow and it could be short which by the
way has an interesting implication which
is one of the things we'd like to
understand is what's special about now
yeah what's now mean around this time
what's special around this time is that
this is the uh period in time when the
most number of galaxies will have formed
in a cycle and if you like the most
number of intelligent species will have
formed in a cycle before we end before
we enter a period of contraction which
as you say will bring our demise uh
because we'll we'll go into a state of
high temperature once again during the
bounce so in a sense it's a kind of
interesting uh answer to the what's
special about why are we here now rather
than at sometime in the future when
there because there was no time in the
future that we could be formed so in a
sense it we have a a specialness within
our cycle
but if the Cycles have always been and
will always be we're just again not
special so in some sense maybe we get a
mixture of the philosophical perspective
that that Peter you were describing so
we're we're pretty much at a time I just
like to get sort of a a final word maybe
can just go down the line where do you
see this kind of cosmological science
going in the next few years are there
going to be experiments that can start
to adjudicate between these competing
ideas well there's there's one
observational matter that there was a s
of false alarm on a few years ago and
that is that if you look at polarized
light when you have polarized sunglasses
and you tilt it you can see blocking and
letting in light at different angles off
of reflected light off the window of a
car for instance and if you look at the
cosmic microwave background it's
polarized too and there's a pattern to
it inflation predicts that there sort of
a handedness to this that the
gravitational waves will create a
certain kind of twist in that pattern
and the cyclic model does not so as
these observations get better and better
eventually they'll be you we'll either
see it or we won't see it and you won't
see it with better and better accuracy
or you will see it uh that that would be
something that would in addition to
theoretical concerns of the type that
Paul's raised and the simulation
concerns Anna's raised that would be an
observational a remarkable observational
consequence and and you know and so Anna
if we were to see that particular
signature what how would that affect
your thinking on these ideas well first
of all it would be great right I mean if
we saw something like that that would
mean that a whole bunch of models is
probably out namely you know this this
Contracting model is probably not the
right story yeah and you know I have
been always asked especially because I
saw started to work on this when I was
young I didn't have tenure and all that
stuff why are you working on something
that could be wrong you know that's um
but you know as a scientist you should
only work on things that should be wrong
so I think it's great we learned
something could be wrong no no no
sorry should be wrong no but but really
you know I mean I I just think that um
we have learned something I mean what
you want to learn something and if you
hadn't explored this that adds
definitely to the value of the
experiment we should name it it says the
Simon Observatory experiment this is up
in the mountains already in Chile this
was just built up so it will be running
we will see first light in a few months
and within 5 to 10 years we will know so
I think this idea you know just to pan
back to what Peter was saying and and
just we were talking about that you can
just within 100 years or thousand years
go from philosophical thinking to to are
we special does time have a beginning a
space extended to actually we can check
it we can write on theories we can pen
land paper we can simulate it and then
we can go up on the mountain in Chile
and we can check it that's a huge
progress so I am happy either way
because we learned something yeah and
but but definitely you know if if it if
if it detect those signals then this
idea is wrong and that's just it yeah
but that's very important because we
just know me important yeah so Paul
final word I mean again if if the
particular polarization pattern that
Peter made reference to that seems to be
uh a a likely outcome of inflation but
not actually a definite outcome it's
perhaps worth noting it depends there
are definite outcomes okay fair enough
yeah that's part of your other argument
but if we do see this which is not
compatible with your cyclic model where
will that leave your thinking on
cosmology will you go will you try to
make inflation work go back and try to
fix it or are you on to something else
yeah I having worked on inflation for a
number of years I think it's not fixable
I think the problems with inflation have
just grown more and more Ser more and
more in number and more and more in
seriousness as we've come to understand
those problems better so I don't see I
personally don't think uh it can surv I
I I I think it's in Ser very serious
trouble now and I don't see it being
fixed myself right so we need yet
another idea and you'd want an but we
have learned something I think is very
profound which is there exists a
smoothing mechanism we never imagined
before and it Smooths everywhere in the
universe and we happen to observe our
universe has this remarkable homogene
isotropy we can't lose that I I mean
that's a that's a that really changes my
own thinking about how I think about
these two different theories and they're
no longer really in my view competitive
because one inflation
produces a Multiverse of every
possibility in homogenity curvature
anything you like and doesn't really
predict any particular one being likely
and the other one actually produces a
universe which matches what we see
powerfully and and doesn't allow you any
flexibility from that so to me that's a
uh that's a GameChanger in thinking and
so if I were going to look for another
theory I somehow have to I I want to
save that idea
because it's remarkable uh and it may
not be slow contraction maybe there's
some other way producing it but it's not
going to be inflation that's what we saw
in the inflation example it does the
opposite if you get if you start off not
smooth enough it just runs away the nons
smoothness runs away well it'll be an
exciting 5 10 years as we wait for
Simon's Observatory to give some insight
and uh once that comes through maybe
we'll join up again and analyze where
we've gotten so please join me in
thanking the panel
[Music]
here